also spieler 10 10 mit mit abspann 11 das also dass sie so ungefähr abschätzen
können
wenn der erste stream dabei war der wird sich vielleicht noch daran erinnern das
ist das wo wir am hafen uns zu dem boot auf das boot gestellt haben hier
irgendwo durch oder nicht darum sind wir hier sind wir das boot gegangen und ich
glaube hier es gibt das speedrun auch glaube das speedrun gibt irgendwie die
hallo es gibt irgendwie direkt zu hier mit rumgeklitsche also spielt es halbe
game gar nicht ohne wird gestalzt der typ der wird gestalzt
der wird gestalzt. BAM! Stahlskill. BAM BAM BAM BAM BAM BAM BAM BAM zack da geht
er daun was das stream war daun ja das lag aber an twitch oder
ich habe das nicht mitgekriegt dass das stream daun war
das lag aber an twitch oder oder lag das an mir zwei minuten oder so
habe ich nicht mitgekriegt was war denn das letzte von dem game was sie gesehen
habe ich gucke nicht immer auf die vorschau den f-spam habe ich nicht
gesehen dann war es vielleicht die telekom wieder
ach ernsthaft die devs die nicht kommunizieren die devs die nicht das
heißt ihr habt noch nicht mal den level wechsel gesehen oder hatte den level
wechsel gesehen
nee okay mal gucken ob ich noch was zum laden habe nee leider nicht im
prinzip war das aber auch am ende des levels wir sind mit dem boot wieder
zurück in die in die anfangsstadt gefahren und müssen jetzt halt den bösen
necromancer aufhalten so sieht es aus
es lag bestimmt an der telekom es könnte aber auch an twitch liegen man
weiß dass die so genau
telekom stabilität ist so fail in letzter zeit habe da nicht gesehen wie
cool ich die wachen gebäscht habe
schreckt
ich habe es leider verkackt dieses jahr ich wollte ja eigentlich ursprünglich
juni media abbestellen weil ich mir so gedacht habe kein mensch braucht zwei
internetanschlüsse vor allem wenn der zweite internetanschluss 50 euro im
monat kostet oder sogar noch mehr 60 und ich wollte im endeffekt juni media
abbestellen und nur noch für fernseh dalassen und rest wieder die telekom weil
bei telekom habe ich ja eh mittlerweile vdsl und ich brauche halt ordentlichen
upload für stremsor und zeug und ich habe es dieses jahr verkackt zu kündigen
bei juni media ich habe den monat verpasst im august kündigen mussten
zwei monate vorher habe ich verpasst so im nachhinein bin ich eigentlich ganz
froh weil die zuverlässigkeit der telekom ist so unter aller sau ich weiß
gar nicht wie man das hinkriegt als das telekom hinter das ist teilweise sonntag
morgens immer stunde weg wie kriegt man das hin
dass wirklich dass das ganz kräutig von der telekom der wird gebäscht
hallo lasst mich rein die lassen mich wirklich rein das aber sehr nett von
euch achtung der wird jetzt geschreckt da ist er da braucht bücher
telekom ist halt ich verstehe es halt echt nicht wie man das hinkriegen kann
so schlecht juni media ist in dem fall besser
juni team hat aber keinen gescheiten upload
vielleicht kommen den du stellst guck mal ob das uns vorbeiläuft ganz deutschland
er schickt ja leider komm her krasse bogi stellzah da wirst du gemessert
ist
Die betet
Okay, die machen nicht auf
Ich muss sich überlegen ich bezahle jetzt quasi irgendwie 120 euro für internet und fernseh im monat
Wegen, zwei anbietern das ist eigentlich komplett lächerlich
Qualitätseinstellungen sind wieder weg ist denn wenigstens 1080p noch da
Hallo hallo warum sieht er mich nicht ist er komplett beschränkt oder was
Oh der hat nicht gesehen oh was gehen ab da der der ist aber ich war auf speed unterwegs
Was sagt eigentlich obs läuft das stream wenigstens ordentlich jetzt ja gut
Es ist gerade gegen uns sind wir hier stehen geblieben jetzt überhaupt
Hier sind wir wir haben den typ noch nicht gestellt egal scheiß drauf jolo wir haben eh
nach kampf bild
Warum ist der typ so schnell und die normalen wachen so lahm special wache hier nein wir
machen keine hebel auf
Keine hebel aufmachen oh das werden immer mehr
Da macht warum schießt er durch mein schild achtung achtung messer
Fünf gigabyte ja wofür man hat ram jetzt verwenden wozu hat man viel ram verwendet
Na na na mit dem schwert
Oh den hat es zerrissen den hat es richtig zerrissen
Jetzt können wir das life lead schwert nehmen dann kriegen wieder mehr hells
Wir haben uns auf der arme als server mit zwei terabyte ram also da gehen immer noch
mehr
Die kriegen aber echt voll auf die fresse
Warum alles nicht das ding ist übelst undurchsichtig wo ist hier was wo geht es hier lang
Ich glaube es nicht er hat sich bei einem stells attempt widersetzt
Schreckt so gibt es hier irgendwas zu looten
Oh da doch loot
Futter loot hells cat oh was was hab ich aufgehoben
Wo ist mein wo ist mein food das sind leben
Life lead schwert weiter gehts
Aus welcher richtung bin ich denn jetzt gekommen eigentlich
Oh hier gehts weiter
Ich gehe noch mal zurück ich will wissen was auf der anderen seite ist
Ich hab bestimmt irgendwas verpasst
Weil man konnte ja einmal links rum einmal rechts rum gehen ich bin links rum gegangen
So ein teufel soll ein ram tarfeln sein
Jetzt gehen wir mal die andere richtung
Ist das dark souls royal ja ja richtig
Von den daisymachern ne sorry nicht von den wartsmachern ist das
Also das ist quasi
Die die warts typen die haben doch bestimmt schon extra battle royale oder
Das haben die sich doch nicht entgehen lassen da auch die leute wieder zu scammen
Hier ist ja gar nichts zum portal ja da kommen wir her das weiß ich
Hier ist loot und hier ist
Ah ne hier waren wir noch nicht interessant doch hier haben wir die gegner vorhin geschnitzelt
Hier ist ja gar nichts das hätten wir uns sparen können hier lang zu gehen
Aber wir wissen jetzt auch wir haben nichts verpasst das ist natürlich auch nicht schlecht
Fortnite z das find ich cool
Aber ne die haben das ist fortnite z ist das dann also
Man die die wollen sich ja nicht verklagen lassen von von denen
Deswegen deswegen ist es wahrscheinlich wahrscheinlich dann fortnite z oder so von denen
Dass keiner auf die idee kommt zu verklagen
Oder fortnite wie ritter ja das ist auch nicht schlecht
Das kann ich mir bei den typen gut vorstellen aber die haben doch sowas bestimmt
Die scamasen doch laufen die leute
Ist eigentlich war es mittlerweile irgendwie fertig
Moment ich laufe in die falsche richtung in irgendwie in dem zustand wo das was taugt
Ich blicke nicht durch moment wo geht es lang
Fortnite z fortnite z finde ich aber das ist nice
Fortnite z ja da gibt es verschiedene varianten
Hier sind wir richtig
Pssst
Stellz-Mode aktiviert!
Runter mit dir!
Weg mit euch! Runter mit dir!
Oh! Oh! Oh! WTF!
Au!
Die machen ganz schön Damage.
Hast du noch eine Speerkopse 4? Ja.
Ich spiele das sogar ab und zu noch.
Wobei ich ja auch dort irgendwie mit dem Battle Royale Modus nicht so richtig warm werde und eher den normalen Multiplayer spiele.
Ja, die machen Damage, die Typen.
Ach, das ist das Schwert vom Gegner, das ist einfach durch den halben Raum geflogen.
Ach so.
Ich habe wenig Leben noch.
Sagt mir Bescheid, falls das Stream wieder abgekackt ist.
Spielt der Friseur auch Cort? Nein, der hat keinen Bock mehr.
Der hat keinen Bock mehr auf Cort, auf Cort, hat er keinen Bock mehr.
Sprich COD, sprich das bitte korrekt aus Max.
Es ist nicht Cort, es ist COD.
Die Leute immer früher auf YouTube.
Da kommen wir nicht weiter.
Der Fabian spielt seit, also der Friseur spielt seit irgendwie 2 Jahren oder so nur BDO.
Oh nein.
Bam! Moment, dazu müssen wir jetzt unsere Daggers rausholen wieder.
Oh, das sind die guten, das sind die Upgraded Guards.
Das sind die guten, das sind die Upgraded Guards.
Friendly Fire.
Oh, nice.
Wo ist der andere?
Komm her, zack.
Splatter. Gibt es hier noch Loot?
Das war es immer noch nicht.
Dann kriegt er jetzt einen Fass an den Kopf.
Oh, nein, der will keinen Fass an den Kopf.
Ich will aber nicht einen Fass an den Kopf werfen.
Oh, WTF, die haben mich geownt.
Das geht nicht, das ist per Definition, dürfen die das nicht.
Dafür werden sie jetzt krass geschreckt.
Bam, next.
Zack.
Das waren keine schönen Kills, jetzt wird alles weggeschnetzelt.
Komm her.
Oh.
Sneaky.
Alter, warum machen die so viel Damage?
Das gibt es ja gar nicht.
Ich könnte ja auch Heiltränke nehmen.
Aber Heiltränke sind komplett overrated.
Das muss ohne Heiltränke gehen.
Oh, jawoll.
Oh, nice.
Alle weggeschnetzelt.
So muss das sein.
Jawoll, und wieder volle Leben.
Lifeline Schwert, FTW.
Erste.
Er ist weggekloppt.
Was haben wir hier?
Ah, der Schlüssel.
Das ist der Schlüssel.
Das ist der Schlüssel für diese komische Tür da vorne.
Oh, wir können was specken.
Was haben wir denn?
Ah, wir warten noch ein Skillpunkt, dann specken wir Adrenalin.
Dann können wir zwei Finisher ausführen.
Äh, wie ich falsch rumlaufe.
So mit Orientierung habe ich es nicht so.
Das wisst ihr ja.
Only in Battlefield.
Das haben sie dieses Mal nicht so wirklich zelebriert.
Dieses Only in Battlefield Geschichte bei Battlefield 5.
Ich habe eh das Gefühl,
Battlefield 5, außer so 0815 Werbesprüche, die sie immer machen,
so nach dem Motto, oh, schaut mal hier, das geilste Level aller Zeiten.
Oh, schaut mal hier, ist das ein geiles Game.
So wirklich was zeigen.
So eine wirklich Strategie scheinen sie diesmal nicht zu verfolgen.
Bei Battlefield 4 haben sie die Evolution angepriesen.
Ja, bei Battlefield 1 haben sie sich aufgegeilt an dem Setting.
Aber bei Battlefield 5, ich weiß gar nicht, was da so ihre Standard-Marketing-Strategie ist.
Aber das rettet das Game wahrscheinlich auch nicht mehr.
Ich glaube ehrlich gesagt, Battlefield 5 rettet nichts mehr.
Vielleicht der Battle-Royale-Modus,
so was Spielerzahlen angeht, wenn er was taucht.
Vielleicht eher nicht.
Man kann sie nicht killen.
Aha, was ist denn das?
Hallo, andere Richtung klettern bitte.
Wo sind wir denn hier gelandet?
BTF.
Ach, das ist einfach nur, um den Fight zu umgehen.
Oh, da ist was, da ist was, was denn da?
Secret Items?
Hier, das bringt es nicht wirklich.
Gucken wir mal, wo es hier lang geht.
Hallo, Fuzz.
Ich bin gestunt.
Ich bin gestunt, ich glaube es geht los.
Hier wird nicht gestunt.
Hier wird geschnetzelt.
Jetzt aber, jetzt ist er down.
Jetzt müssen wir mal gucken, ob auch das geheime Tür hochgegangen ist.
Unten im Keller.
Gut.
Schon fast Zombie-Stells.
Ok, Gegengift.
Hier ist nichts.
Jetzt gucken wir noch mal schnell, was rechts in dem Raum gewesen ist.
Komischen Staff brauchen wir nicht, sagt.
Äh, Moment.
Kommen wir von hier?
Nee, wir kommen von da, ne?
Geht es denn hier hinten lang?
Plate Armor, haben wir schon?
Verschlossen.
Ach, hier geht es weiter. Ok, da gucken wir erstmal, was hinten an der Tür war.
Mein Gott, das Level ist aber echt verwirrend.
Das ist aber nichts, könnt ihr euch noch an 4 erinnern?
Das ist aber nichts gegen die Schalter, Rätsel und Spiel...
Spielereien von 4.
Da hast du nämlich gar nicht durchgeblickt.
Ich habe echt mal im Zweifel, dass Battlefield was wird, dass 5 war.
Ich kann auch die Logik nicht verstehen, warum man das...
Die Raume sind nicht so groß jetzt.
Warum man es wirklich 5 nennt, aber das ist halt EA-Marketing-Taktik.
Die ich auch nicht verstehe, ehrlich gesagt, weil ich keinen Sinn darin erkenne.
Aber ist halt so.
Ist so wie es ist in dem Fall, können wir da wirklich nichts dran machen.
Shadowsteel-Dagger, die haben wir auch schon.
Jetzt gucken wir noch mal schnell, ob die Tür unten auf ist.
Im Geheimraum.
Jawoll, oder? Nee.
Da. Ach, man kann die Tür direkt aufmachen.
Kann man nicht.
Okay, Max. Pech gehabt, würde ich sagen.
Ich muss hier unten raus.
So, gehen wir weiter. Wo war jetzt die richtige Tür?
Da, ne? Hier hinten.
Verwirrende Level.
Da habe ich zu smalles Brain für.
Moin, Sweet. G6.
Gehts weiter, oder?
Ich hätte auch lieber im Gegenwart Battlefield.
Ich finde die Argumentation von den Ultra-Battlefield-Fans immer geil.
Das Wizard Grill lebt!
Das Wizard Grill lebt! Ich rette das Wizard Grill!
Ich war nicht schnell gelocht mit meinen...
Ich war nicht schnell gelocht mit meinen Snipe-Künsten.
Aber nachdem ich das Game schon kenne, weiß ich, was kommt.
Best.
Gibt es hier noch was zu looten?
Was wollte ich gerade sagen?
Ich finde so die Hardcore-Battlefield-Fans immer geil.
Die sich das alles irgendwie schön reden.
Nach dem Motto, über Battlefield 3 und 4 habt ihr immer alle geheult.
Das ist so Gegenwart.
Dann kamen die jetzt mit Battlefield 1 um die Ecke.
Und die sind immer noch am heulen.
Und jetzt machen sie Battlefield 2.
Battlefield 5 aus dem zweiten Weltkrieg.
Und jetzt ist euch das auch nicht recht.
Ich kann mir das überhaupt nicht recht machen.
DICE ist aber ganz schön arm dran.
Die reden sich das alles übelst schön.
Man muss es ja auch mal ehrlich sagen.
Es ist eigentlich scheiße egal, in welchem Setting das ist.
Mir persönlich würde ein moderner Setting am besten gefallen.
Aber das Wichtigste ist, dass das Game im Kern was taugt.
Was Battlefield 1 meiner Meinung nach überhaupt nicht gemacht hat.
Oh.
Der hat es aber instan zerlegt.
Mal gucken, ob wir was stelzen können.
Iron Tear.
Ist der French?
Da wäre es Oratier oder so.
Da wäre der Typ auf Französisch.
Au.
So gut, dass ihr das nicht gehört habt da drüben.
Achtung, Stelzen.
Jaja, laber nur rum.
Achtung, die werden jetzt gestelzt.
Was?
Der hat mich gesehen, Zaurei.
Aber zum Glück könnt ihr ja nichts.
Zum Glück seid ihr so Kacknubs.
Kacknubs können nichts.
Easy Clap.
Moment, wird von mir jetzt erwartet, dass ich dem Wizard Krill hinterher springe?
Um es zu retten?
Ich mag das Wizard Krill überhaupt nicht.
Weil es an mir geht, will man das gar nicht retten.
Ok, das ist nicht so gedacht.
Ach, da geht es lang.
Ich frage mich, warum man das in so einem Haus, wo Leute drinne wohnen, so baut.
Willst du jedes Mal, wenn du aufs Klo musst, eine halbe Stunde kurbeln, bis du durchs Tor kannst?
Aber wahrscheinlich, wenn man Necromancer ist, hat man keine Probleme mit.
Da muss man nicht aufs Klo.
Die machen nichts mehr.
Krass aufgelöste Bodentexture, by the way.
Aber das Spiel ist von 2008.
Ich gebe Xana recht.
Aber unser Held möchte das Wizard Krill retten.
Also machen wir das.
So, nachdem jetzt kein Spoiler mehr ist, wenn ich sage, dass das Wizard Krill noch lebt.
Ihr könnt euch ja schon mal überlegen, im nächsten Level müssen wir uns entscheiden.
Ob wir auf der Seite von Xana stehen oder auf der Seite von Lyanna.
Also sprich, auf der Seite von unserem Sukubus im Kopf oder auf der Seite von Wizard Krill.
Ups, warum habe ich denn jetzt meine, äh, nicht Taschenlampe, meine, ich weiß nicht, wie es heißt, meine Magic Taschenlampe angemacht.
Ich finde das geil, wie er das Schwert immer raus und...
So ein bisschen wie, warte mal, so ein bisschen wie dieser Salzstreu-Typ, kennt ihr den?
Der sich quasi dieses Salz über den Unterarm kleiten lässt in das Essen.
Kennt ihr den, diesen Salzstreu-Typ?
Der macht den Arm auch so ähnlich wieder.
Ne, so nicht.
So nicht, so ja.
Ne, jetzt macht das nicht mehr.
Egal.
Ich weiß nicht, wie der Typ heißt. Der, der so Salzstreut.
Ihr denkt euch jetzt wahrscheinlich, the fuck, was redet der Max für da komische Dinger, äh, der Salzstreu-Typ.
Da gab es doch mal einen Typ.
Ja, genau, genau, Last Fanboy, der Salt B.
Genau, den meine ich.
Spodas. Spiderman.
Jetzt bräuchten wir das Spiderschwein.
Jetzt könnten wir von hier oben runter droppen lassen auf die Spille.
Erstmal die kleinen Viecher platt machen.
Äh, hallo? Was? Warum bin ich vergiftet?
Ah!
All die Spodas in dem Game sind so eklig.
Wut?
Face!
Oh, ja.
Okay.
Okay, jetzt müssen wir die Spoda noch irgendwie killen.
Wie immer wir das genau machen sollen.
Wir jumpen da jetzt einfach drauf.
Komm her.
Au!
Okay, ich lad noch mal neu. Das war definitiv nicht so gedacht.
Die Spinner hatten Mordhack, eindeutig.
Die weiß wo ich bin.
Spidersenses.
Au!
Die awnen die Spinner einfach so. Kein Ding.
Bam!
Schild weg, zwei Händer regelt.
Wir müssen mal kurz, äh, heilen.
Wie, das hat vorbei gehauen.
Oh, Special. Bam!
Zack! Das war ein nice Hit.
Ist sie down? Sie ist down!
Jawoll!
Da gehts down!
Down gehts.
Alles down.
Gut.
Wizard Krill einpacken und abhauen würde ich sagen.
Ja, Xana.
Ich wollte auch nicht, der Held wollte.
Was passiert, ich muss es mal ausprobieren.
Was passiert wenn ich die kille?
Da freut sich Xana bestimmt.
Da, Xana freut sich.
Schaut mal neu, wir wollen das Wizard Krill ja nicht killen.
Wenn ich hab sie erst gerettet und jetzt soll ich sie killen.
Das wäre ja irgendwie ziemlich beklackt, ne?
Eine Spoda, die machen wir mal mit Range Attacks platt.
Diana nicht davor rennen.
Das, die kennt da nix.
Da sieht man einfach mal wieder wie unfähig Wizard Krills sind.
Und das Demon, guck mal habt ihr gesehen hier krasse, Environment Effects.
Dass Dämonen da einfach besser sind in dem Fall.
Das neue Dark Souls sieht komisch aus.
Ja, so ist das halt mit All the Axes Alphas.
Ich darf ja eigentlich gar nicht streamen des neuen Dark Souls, aber ich hab mir gedacht, komm. Scheiß drauf.
Dark Souls NG.
Guck mal wie sie Kraft bewegt.
Guck mal.
Also wie wir schon feststellen, die beiden Mädels mögen sich nicht sonderlich.
Naja, das war jetzt schon krasser Chebat, oder? Ich finde es ist offensichtlich, dass das nicht die Dark Souls All the Axes Alphas ist.
Aber könnte sein, man weiß ja nie.
Moment, Leala, wo bist du hin? Die hat keinen Bock, die bleibt jetzt einfach da stehen.
Also, wenn ich der krasse Ober Necromancer Anführer bin, dann würde ich natürlich auch mein Tagebuch mitten in mein Zimmer stellen.
Auf so einem riesen fetten Buch, dass es jeder lesen kann.
So, das ist es. Aber gut, ich mein, wenn man der Böse ist in so einer Story, dann macht man halt einfach so Dinger.
Gut, wir haben das jetzt gelesen.
Oh, jetzt ist er böse. Jetzt ist er mad, jetzt will er so ownen.
Ich habe noch mal CTF Hacking Challenges gemacht. CTF? Capture the Flag? Was? Nee.
Leala, gegen ADAD Spam kommst du eh nicht an. ADAD Spam ist in jedem Game einfach das Beste.
Hitet mich keiner.
Auf geht's. Komm mit. Move dich.
Was sind denn Capture the Flag Hacking Challenges?
Was genau soll das sein? Sagt mir nichts.
Du bleibst mal hier. Hier bleiben. Ich mach das.
Nein, da ist ja noch mehr.
Das war's.
Bufffood.
Es ist gar kein Bufffood. Schwachsinn. Healthfood.
Jawoll. Let's go.
Ach so. Nee, hab ich noch nicht gemacht.
Ach man.
Wow, da fliegt er. Wie, der lebt noch? Der lebt noch?
Warum lebt denn der Typ so lang? Jetzt aber.
Oh, die machen mir ein bisschen viel Damage, die Jungs hier.
Die Typen machen mir ein bisschen viel Damage, aber das war ja auch wieder ein total bescheuertes Opening.
Eigentlich wollte ich den Typen messern und der andere Dude hat mich gesehen.
Wir warten, bis er vorbei ist. Dann messern wir den einen, dann holen wir das Zweihänder-Schwert raus und alle werden gebaut.
Warum kommst du jetzt zu mir?
Okay, Schwert raus.
Das mit Stels, das wird nichts mehr.
Komm, weiter.
Wie er ausweicht? Wie er ausweicht?
Der erlaubt sich aber was.
Oh, hinter mir, hinter mir, hinter mir.
Wo ist noch was?
Wo ist denn der passende Necromancer dazu, da unten?
Komm her.
Bam, zack.
Die halten aber auch was aus.
Wie viel will der Typ noch aushalten? Ich hab den achtmal gehittet oder so. Jetzt, jetzt hat er daun.
Du willst da einen Krill abholen?
Leanna, wo steckst du?
Du darfst mitkommen.
Auf. Ich hab aufgeräumt.
Hier war doch irgendwo noch eine Tür zum Aufmachen gerade.
Warum es keinen Nachfolger gab, das frage ich mich bis heute. Ich gehe davon aus, dass es kommerziell nicht so erfolgreich war.
Aber es wäre geil, weil ich bin der Meinung, es hat das beste Nahkampf-Kampfsystem, das ich je gesehen habe in einem Game.
Hier gibt es auch was zum Aufmachen.
Nichts mehr.
Aufpassen, dass ich Leanna nicht haue.
Okay, wir kommen von da, das heißt wir müssen nach hier.
Kommt sie? Ja.
Also wie gesagt, ich finde es schade, dass sich das Game nicht gut verkauft hat und dass es keinen Nachfolger gibt.
Das ist wirklich blöd.
Ich habe schon gedacht, das Game wäre gecrashed.
Und Tschüss.
Ich dachte, ich kann sie runterfahren.
Ich muss sie.
Lass die Feministen sehen.
Ja, das Studio gibt es noch, das sind die mit Dishonored.
Und die haben allgemein ein ziemlich gutes Line-Up, wenn man sich die Spiele anguckt.
Die haben eigentlich nur gutes Zeug gemacht.
Ich habe kaum Bullshit produziert.
Ich habe halt auch nicht so viel gemacht, aber kaum Bullshit.
Hier gibt es ja nichts. Wozu habe ich das jetzt aufgemacht?
Ach doch, da. Was ist das?
Hab ich schon. Brauche ich alles nicht.
Health Potion, ja das ist nice.
Ich habe da drüben auch was vergessen, seht ihr?
Immersives Atmungserlebnis.
Ist das Spiel von EA? Nein, das ist Ubisoft.
Also Ubisoft hat das Published.
Auf, komm mit.
Ach nee, sie wollte ja da bleiben.
So, wir haben 19 Skill Points, wir können jetzt mal was ordentliches specken.
Adrenalin wird gespeckt, nice.
Jetzt können wir zwei Finisher ausführen.
Und wer den ersten Stream verfolgt hat, wird es jetzt auch gleich sehen.
Jetzt kommen wir wieder in die Stadt zurück, wo wir ganz am Anfang drin gewesen sind.
Jetzt echt? Ernsthaft?
Galaga. Das Game taugt.
Wasserfall Experience.
Ich werde die Ghouls ownen.
Jetzt wird er.
Ich finde es halt geil, das sie zu tun als wäre das eine besondere Wache, die halt genauso aussieht wie jede andere Wache auch.
Die Wache ist bugged, würde ich sagen.
Ich habe jetzt zwei Ultimates.
Komm her, komm her, komm her.
Ist ja nice, dass ihr euch alle so reinkicken lasst.
Ich muss mal ein stärkeres Schwert nehmen.
Wie viele sind denn das?
Die machen nichts mehr.
Jetzt ist Gollum geforkt.
Sieht zumindest fast so aus, das Viech.
Und hier ist noch was.
Noch mehr Gollum-Forks.
Wo ist es da? Oh, damit gebogt.
Wie, deshalb war kein Treffer?
Die Bogen-Skill-Suck in dem Game.
Also ich habe es nicht gespeckt.
Das kann gar nicht gut sein.
Ist er down?
So.
Hallo, hochklettern?
Schild haben wir schon.
Oh, das ist aber eine nice Hintergrund-Textur.
Oder was sagt ihr?
Also ich würde sagen, da könnte sich Battlefield schon mal eine Scheibe von abschneiden.
Vor allem vor diesem Gebäude da hinten.
Das ist ja schon eine sehr, sehr nice Textur.
Kann man sich da drüber schwingen irgendwie?
Das geht natürlich nicht.
Ich glaube, ich weiß, was ich machen muss.
Gut.
Moment.
Hier kommen wir genau da wieder raus, wo wir herkommen.
Das ist nicht im Sinne des Erfinders.
Und ich würde sagen, sackt, Alter.
Sackt.
Richtig.
Ich hätte ein bisschen schneller laufen können.
Flieg.
Wo ist die Wache hin?
Erklärt mir mal bitte, wo die Wache hin ist.
Guck mal, da unten ist was.
Erst mal ein bisschen Platz machen.
Health Potion.
Nice.
Moment mal kurz.
Gerade mal was antworten.
Ja, fertig.
Ich kann sie nicht rumdrehen.
Würdest du eigentlich sagen, die erste Person an sich macht das Spiel zu einem amoklaufverheerlichten Killerspiel?
Alles.
Das sind amok... äh... nicht amoklaufende Killerspiele.
Alles sind... alles hier.
Ganz, ganz schrecklich.
Teufelszeug.
Moment.
Weißt ihr, was ich gut finde bei dieser ganzen Killerspiel-Diskussion?
Dass es die Diskussion eigentlich gar nicht mehr gibt.
Irgendwelche Leute bei RTL oder so werben das zwar ab und zu noch mal auf.
Aber in der heutigen Zeit, es ist einfach Mainstream.
Wie ich im letzten Video gesagt habe.
Mesut Özil hat eine E-Sport-Organisation der eigenen.
Oder...
Viele Leute, ja.
Und das ist einfach mittlerweile im Mainstream angekommen.
Das heißt, die Diskussion hat sich erledigt.
Bis auf Leute wie der Pfeiffer oder der... wie heißt der andere?
Der Spitzer.
Der gibt's ja auch noch.
Der Spitzer erzählt ja auch immer, wie geschädlich das für das kindliche Gehirn ist und sowas.
Ähm...
Was macht eigentlich Regine Pfeiffer?
Ja, außerdem kräht da kein Hahn mehr nach.
Aber die sterben aus.
Ist so.
Die sterben aus.
Also im Prinzip ist der Kampf, was Killerspiele...
Oh Mensch, die laufen in die falsche Richtung.
Der Anti-Killer-Spiel-Sache.
Oder der Kampf für Games in der Gesellschaft.
So anerkennend.
Und das ist gewonnen.
Ja, den gibt's nicht.
Den gibt's nicht mehr.
Der ist vorbei.
Da haben wir gesiegt quasi in dem Fall.
Hätt's gleich aufmachen können.
Bogen brauchen wir nicht.
Arrows nehmen wir mit.
Piss dich, Alter.
Ach stimmt, ich darf den da gar nicht killen.
Ich bin der Anti-AD-Spammer.
Und der Cyclops ist eines meiner leichtesten Übungen, das Viech zu owen.
Wir wissen ja mittlerweile, wie das geht.
Keine großartigen Taktiken probieren.
Sondern einfach fünfmal Jump-Slashen und down ist er.
Skill-Points.
Wir kriegen so viele Skill-Points.
Ich weiß gar nicht mehr, was ich skillen soll.
Als nächstes skillen wir Endu.
Sollen wir den Cyclops mal down?
Wo geht's denn hier lang?
Nice.
Voll ins Auge getroffen.
Komm her.
Jetzt wirst du gebashed.
Bam.
Die können nix.
Scheiß auf Taktik.
Guck mal.
Easy.
Easy as fuck.
Jump-Slash.
Power-Attack.
Down ist er.
Piss dich.
Oh fuck, ich darf den da nicht hauen.
Oh, wo geht's hier lang?
Also bevor wir jetzt da lang gehen, gucken wir erst mal, wo es hier in den Kanal reinging.
Weil wir wollen ja keine Secret Areas und Skill-Points und Zeug verpassen.
Ähm.
Hallo?
What the fuck?
Leitern.
Leitern in Spielen.
Gibt es irgendein Game, wo Leiter ordentlich funktionieren?
Sagt mir eins.
Sagt mir ein Game jetzt ohne nach zu überlegen, wo funktionieren Leiter gut.
Alter, was ist das?
Was ist das?
Gothic 1.
Ja, genau.
Okay, ich möchte einfach nur die Leiter klettern, ne?
Alter, Rund...
Ey, Leitern in Spielen, das ist der Wahnsinn, ey.
Okay, ich drücke nach unten und er geht nach oben und ich drücke nach oben und er geht nach
unten.
Okay, jetzt.
Oh.
Leiter-Action.
Source-Leitern.
Ja, Source-Leitern sind fast...
Sind mit die Schlimmsten.
Aber Half-Life 1-Leitern war auch schon so.
Half-Life 1-Eitern war das Schlimmste...
Eitern?
Ja, genau, also Half-Life 1-Eitern war das Schlimmste, da bist du nämlich gleich schnell
hoch wie gelaufen und bist dann so gesleitet so irgendwie an der Leiter.
Oh, ein Mana- und Life-Auffüllpilz.
Oh, hier geht's rein.
Wo geht's denn hier lang?
Gibt's Loot?
Erstmal die Einrichtung demolieren.
Kiste, Heil-Tränke, die nehmen wir mit.
Geht's hier hoch?
Und hier war doch irgendwo eine Leiter.
Ich finde es gut, dass meine Magietaschen-Lampe kein Mana kostet.
Nee, ich glaube, das war einfach nur ein extra Weg, den Zyklop zu killen.
Brauchen wir nicht, overrated, outdated, jebaited.
Ja, das war nur ein extra Weg, den Zyklop zu killen.
Ah, ein Schlüssel, vielleicht kann ich jetzt oben aufmachen.
Top-Secret, revealed, aber war jetzt aber nicht so geil, gab's ja im Endeffekt nichts
außer ein Heil-Tränke, wie findet ihr eigentlich meine Aussprache von Heil-Tränke?
Die ist schon eigentlich ziemlich nah an dem, wie sie sein sollte, oder?
Heil-Tränke, aber ich finde, da gibt's nicht mal viel Verbesserungspotenzial.
Kann ich hier runter?
Hallo, runter.
Muss ich jetzt wirklich runterlaufen, ja?
Der Heil-Tränke, der Stelzer trinkt den Heil-Tränke, so, auf geht's, ja, ist, ist doch.
Der Typ ist verbackt, oder?
Ich glaub, der Typ ist verbackt.
Der Dude ist verbackt und ich hab gesaved.
Oh, nee, oder?
Der Typ ist backt.
Scheiße.
Scheiße, was machen wir denn jetzt?
Autosave, wir haben noch nen Autosave.
Der Typ ist backt, geil.
Aber wir haben noch nen Autosave.
Nein!
Alter, nicht Izz, MonkaS.
Okay, ähm, wartet mal, war jetzt irgendwas, irgendwas gutes hier im Secret Raum?
Nee, ne, ne, ne, da war nur Mist, da müssen wir nicht noch mal hin.
Aber den Schlüssel nehmen wir mal mit.
Den Schlüssel nehmen wir mal mit, vielleicht können wir damit später noch andere Türen
aufmachen.
Schlüssel sind nie verkehrt zu haben.
Moment, wo war denn jetzt der Schlüssel überhaupt?
Andere Seite, ne?
Lull.
Schlüssel nehmen wir noch mit.
Im Prinzip Schlüssel nehmen wir noch mit, heißt wir machen den ganzen Weg noch warm.
Weil der Weg nicht lang ist, ist ja nur hier runter jetzt.
Ah hier kommen wir auch auf, die sind aber noch gar nicht reingeguckt.
Hier war man noch gar nicht.
Nix drin?
Nix.
Moment.
Was zum Teufel?
Secret Area ohne was drin.
Ach ne, da ist eine Truhe mit einer Helz-Porsche.
Krasses Secret Area.
Dafür muss man unbedingt einen eigenen Raum machen, dass man da eine Helz-Porsche drin
verstecken kann.
Hier war auch noch Crab drin, ne?
Crabber Z.
Voller Helz, jawoll.
Okay, jetzt können wir speichern, jetzt ist der Typ ja durchgelaufen.
So.
Kannst du mit 12 Scale Points nicht die nächsten Scale freischalten, muss mal gucken.
Boah, krasser, stylischer Jumper.
Ich mag Spiele, wo man in der Luft steuern kann, wo man hinfällt.
Da kommt man doch rüber, oder?
Ja easy, kommt man da rüber, wenn da keine Wand wäre.
Wenn wir ihn nicht brauchen würden, würde ich ihm sagen, nur weiter zu rennen, anstrengend Mann.
Was jetzt?
Game Crash?
Alter Falter, ey, das ist aber Windows 10 Problem.
Das Game ist früher nie gecrasht, ich kann mich da nicht dran erinnern, dass das früher
auch so viel gecrasht wäre.
Das ist ein Problem mit Windows 10, das hab ich auch schon gelesen, das Spaktrum.
So, dann können wir jetzt die Typen auch mal außen.
Oh, den hat's aber zerrissen, richtig.
Bam!
Für die Wand.
Der Flick, habt ihr den gesehen, ha?
360, Bein ab, hack, flip.
Flick, ich flipp.
Das hat sich nicht gelohnt, dass wir den Schlüssel mitgenommen haben.
Es gibt in dem Spiel kein Rechtssystem oder so, also kein irgendwie Gesinnungssystem, du
kannst alles killen, was du willst.
Das juckt nicht.
Solange es nicht questrelevant ist, ist es vollkommen egal.
Du kannst auch jegliche Wache bashen, überhaupt kein Ding.
So Leute, jetzt müssen wir uns entscheiden, ob wir, das Game hat vier verschiedene Enten,
ich kann, also ich kann Ihnen nicht alle Enten erzählen, weil das wird noch andere Sachen
spoilern, aber die Enten unterscheiden sich je nachdem, welches Mädel man auswählt,
ja.
Auf der anderen Stelle haben wir jetzt hier einmalig die Gelegenheit, uns von Xana zu
reinigen, da kann man in so ein Tempel gehen und dann ist sie weg und das findet das Wizard
Grill ganz toll und die findet einen dann ganz, ganz geil, ja, oder aber man lässt
das ganze bleiben, dann findet ein Xana übelst geil und das Wizard Grill hasst einen.
Was wollen wir machen?
Ich persönlich bin der Meinung, Wizard Grill ist beste, äh, nicht Wizard Grill, äh,
Demon Grill ist beste, wenn ihr wollt, können wir uns aber angucken, was passiert, wir können
mal ein Save punkten, wir können mal, wir können mal safen, wenn ihr wollt, können
wir mal gucken, was passiert, wenn wir das Demon Grill austreiben.
Wir können uns ja mal angucken, wie das aussieht, wir laden das aber neu, weil ich will das
Demon Grill behalten, lol, oh, eine nice Rüstung, hat sich doch gleich mal Endo 3 Specken gelohnt,
aber wir können ja nicht speichern, ok, jetzt gucken wir mal, was passieren würde, wenn
wir das Demon Grill austreiben, aus uns, klingt irgendwie komisch.
Aber das machen wir nicht, wir laden dann neu und behalten das Demon Grill, imaginäre
Demon Grill's beste, ja, hier kletter ich auch immer in der Kirche hoch, so weißt du,
sonntags einfach mal in die Kirche, dann 3 mal mit dem Arm da hochgezogen, mit einem
Arm natürlich nur, piss dich an, wow, also das, das, das Demon Grill möchte nicht ausgetrieben
werden, aber wenn wir das trotzdem machen, passiert das.
Ok, jetzt geht's los, ja, ok, ja, ok, ja, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok,
ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok,
Now, go forth and reclaim the skull of the seventh dragon, ere the world end in ash and flame.
Und jetzt, äh, mag uns das die, äh, die, äh, wie heißt sie, jetzt mag uns Lyanna, jetzt findet uns Lyanna ganz geil und ganz toll und ist übelst scharf auf uns, weil wir uns hier von Xana gereinigt haben.
Aber, wir haben uns ja dazu entschieden, wir wollen Xana behalten, deswegen laden wir jetzt nochmal neu.
Wir machen das jetzt nicht nochmal, ich hol mir plus die Rüstung.
Nee, hab ich auch nicht vor.
So, jetzt aber, der erste Kick hat, oh, oh, der fliegt aber, den hat's zerrissen.
So, jetzt ziehen wir uns die ordentliche Rüstung an.
Und den Typ ownen wir noch.
So, und jetzt hauen wir uns von diesem Tempel ab.
Und das Gute ist, wir haben jetzt immer noch unsere, unsere Demon Form am Start, weil wir das nicht gemacht haben.
Das ist das Beste. Kann man den Endgegner damit später besser ownen.
Hallo.
Drüber springen.
Ich würd sagen, wir haben die richtige Wahl getroffen.
Kommt man nicht rein.
Fuck, ich hab kein Endo mehr.
Arm ab.
Kiste in your face.
Wo stellts denn die Gegner dann?
Oh, ups.
Ich hab die Wache noch geownen nebenbei.
Wo ist der Typ?
Zack.
Stop, jetzt haben wir's.
Du willst mich nicht angreifen, oder?
Ich weiß auch nicht, warum ich den Typen jetzt kille.
Aber nachdem es kein Gesinnungssystem gibt, kann man eh alles killen.
Oh, was ist das?
Wasser.
Unterirdisch stellts Hüllenkram.
Ins Def.
Schild.
Was, Fire Shield? Nice, das nehmen wir.
Das andere Schild wird gekickt.
Orc Schild wird gekickt.
Stealbar wird gekickt.
Axe wird gekickt.
Riecht hier sonst noch was?
Nope.
Moment.
Ach, da geht's lang.
Äh, raus da.
Ich hab Hunger.
Das hat sich überhaupt nicht gelohnt, dass wir den Schlüssel mitgenommen haben vorhin, ne?
Also, ich hab gedacht, wir können vielleicht in der Stadt ein paar Türen aufmachen, aber das war...
Debate. Eine richtige Debate.
Noch mehr so Viecher. Kommt mal her.
Schreckt.
Oh, das sind aber ganz so viele.
Achtung.
Bein ab.
Noch mal ein Bein ab.
Tür. Oh, die geht auf. Sehr schön.
Ein Quiver.
Moment, hier geht's...
Hier geht's raus aus dem Level.
Na gut, anderen Weg gibt's ja auch nicht mehr. Gehen wir hier lang.
Safe.
Bin ich froh, dass das Game vorher nicht geklitscht ist, ne? Wo der Typ an der Treppe hing.
Sonst hätten wir alles immer neu spielen dürfen.
Aber das hätte ich wahrscheinlich nicht gemacht.
Also jetzt, jetzt quasi noch mal sechs Stunden noch mal spielen.
Hätte ich echt keinen Nerv drauf gehabt.
Also, da kann ein Game noch so sehr Bock machen.
Das Gleiche noch mal spielen.
Einfach, weil es geklitscht hat, ist, glaube ich, hat keiner Bock drauf.
Lightning Shield. Taugt das was?
Das hab ich früher nie genommen.
Weiß bloß nicht mal warum.
Warum eigentlich nicht?
Ah, ich hab's nicht genommen, weil das so komisch leuchtet. Genau.
Gehen wir immer auf den Keks.
Au!
Ja, immer viel speichern. Das ist das gute Hinweis, die man braucht.
Wir machen einen richtigen Safe.
Einen ordentlichen Safe.
Oh, Einrichtung, Schreddern.
Komm, Top.
Bread.
Hat er sich angeschlichen von hinten.
Übrigens, Zweikampf, Zweihand mit dem Schwert finde ich viel angenehmer als mit dem Schild.
Schild ist immer so nervig, wenn man diese Angriffe macht beim Rennen.
Dann schlägt er rum und dann schlägt es so komisch.
Guck, da trifft man nichts.
Ganz merkwürdig.
Wie lange die rumliegen.
Zweihandbeste.
Kommt mir fast ja vor, wie in irgendeinem Vampir-Spiel oder so, wo du das aufspießen musst.
Kommt man hier hoch?
Nee.
Oder vielleicht doch.
Hast du eigentlich mal Proton-Weinfach ausprobiert?
Habe ich nicht.
Aber das ist ja das, was in Steam integriert ist mittlerweile.
Ich habe gelesen, dass es ganz gut funktioniert.
Natürlich hasst du die üblichen Probleme, dass manche Sachen halt klitschen und so.
Aber es ist der richtige Ansatz.
Auf jeden Fall.
Meine Valve geht ja auch die Microsoft-Only-Geschichte ein bisschen auf den Sack.
Ich finde es ja auch nicht schlecht, wenn Spiele auch unter anderen Systemen laufen würden.
So können am Endeffekt alle von profizieren.
Aber bis Games wirklich gut auf Linux laufen und viele Games für Linux kommen,
da wird noch ein bisschen Zeit vergehen.
Nee, das Wasser ist noch zu tief, hat er gesagt.
Oh nee, der kommt hier bestimmt wieder nicht drüber.
Doch.
Zum Glück.
Komisches rumgeklitschen da vor den NPCs.
Haben wir sonst noch was?
Nur eine Potion.
Hier noch was.
Das ist, wo ich, glaube ich, im kompletten Playthrough jetzt nicht eine Scroll verwendet habe.
Okay, Wasser.
Wasser-Risen.
Den wollte ich eigentlich nicht killen, ich wollte den Beschwörungs-Dude killen.
Next.
Fuß ab.
So, jetzt, komm her.
Ihr werdet gekickt wieder.
Oh, vorbei, vorbei, vorbei.
Nächster.
Nächster Versuch.
Jawoll, reingekickt.
Oh, den hat's voll reingehauen.
Kick, Kick.
Willkommen da noch.
Kopf ab.
Und der auch noch, komm her.
Bam.
Den hat's, der ist jetzt irgendwo hingeflogen.
Keine Ahnung, wo.
Water-Level-Risen.
So, die Games haben alle immer so ähnliche Quests.
So nach dem Motto, hm, hier komm ich nicht hoch.
Was musst du machen?
Entweder umlaufen, Brücke hoch.
Irgendwelche Plattform umschwingen lassen.
Irgendwelche Wasser-Dinger auffüllen.
Das ist so Standard.
In Woe ist es anders, in Woe müsste ich noch 20 Blumen für irgendeinen Random-NPC sammeln.
Muss gucken.
Ah, Jebaited.
Geht nicht.
Kommt man eigentlich hier rauf?
Na, geht's nicht lang.
Geht's nicht lang.
Da bleibt ja nicht so viel.
Ach, was denn hier oben?
Health Potion.
Yeah.
Und hier?
Nix.
Da hätte ich jetzt eigentlich gewettet, dass da was drinne ist.
Das war da so schön versteckt, aber man musste einen ordentlichen Jump machen.
Ich dachte, da ist irgendwas drinne.
Aber, Baited.
Was liegt denn da unten?
Das soll ein Baum sein, ok.
Oh.
Dragon.
Hau ab.
Es speit kein Feuer, es speit Blitze.
Auch gut.
Das letzte Viech der Art haben wir in der Mitte vom Game mit diesem Tor gekillt.
Ach, vielleicht kann ich jetzt das...
Das bringt noch nicht, ich muss das Viech erstmal killen.
Moin.
C4 Dagi.
Na, wie praktisch.
Hallo, komm her.
Drache, komm her.
Muss ich jetzt anschießen, dass du herkommst?
Ja.
Nein, vorbei.
Alter, bleib stehen.
Hit.
Ich muss mal kurz mich verpissen und heilen.
Wir haben genug Potions bis zum Ende des Games.
Schreckt.
Was, F?
Doch nicht, ne.
Das hätte ich mitgekriegt.
Kann nix.
Sechs Killpoints, kommen wir davon noch irgendwas Gescheites specken?
Hm.
Wird der Masterkleider jetzt sagen.
Achso, das ist, dass man schneller da hinkommt.
Ich verstehe.
Und wie genau kommt man jetzt wieder hoch?
Gar nicht.
Wahrscheinlich einmal umlaufen, das Ganze.
Dann müssen wir oben an dieses komische Rad und dann die Tür aufmachen auf der anderen
Seite.
Kann man hier hochklettern?
Geh mal weg.
Alter.
Diese Animation.
Es will nicht, es will nicht, jetzt.
Ne, man kann hier gar nicht hochklettern, ne?
Was ist denn das da?
Kann man das kaputt schießen?
Ne.
Egal, scheiß drauf.
Ich hab genug Potions bis zum Ende des Games.
Ich hab genug, ich hab von allem genug bis zum Ende des Games.
Eigentlich brauch ich nicht.
Waffen gut genug.
Ja, jetzt geht die Tür auf.
Schnell.
Weil so schnell müssen wir gar nicht sein, wir können ja da hinschleichen.
Sie ist nicht erfreut.
Sie ist überhaupt nicht erfreut.
Ja, man muss sich tatsächlich in dem Spiel, das ist auch ein, äh, warum klitschst du durch
das Tor?
Was soll das?
Nein.
Ja, man muss sich tatsächlich dem Game entscheiden und die Entscheidung führt zwangsläufig dazu,
dass einer der Hauptcharaktere, dass man einen der Hauptcharaktere killen muss.
Ich kann aber nix.
Hallo?
Warum trifft das nicht?
Sanna freut sich.
Okay Leute, ich muss noch mal ganz kurz schnell aufs Klo.
Okay.
So, ich bin wieder am Start.
Ich muss mir gleich noch was zu essen holen, ich hab übelst Hunger.
Aber jetzt kommt das letzte Level vom Game.
Das heißt, in ungefähr einer halben Stunde oder so sollten wir durch sein, denke ich.
Citi, so sieht's aus. Du hast die Entscheidung leider verpasst. Wir mussten gerade das Wizard Krill killen.
Was ist jetzt los?
Alter.
Was war denn das gerade?
Jawoll, da fliegt er.
Ich finde es ja gut, dass mich Wachen nicht kicken können.
Das Kicken ist das Geilste an dem Game, ohne Scheiß. Das Kicken ist echt das Beste.
Du hattest aber Glück, dass ich mich durch dich selbst geohnt habe.
Oh nein, nicht stunnen Leute. Hört auf mich zu stunnen.
Ihr stunt wird nicht.
Alter, was ist los hier?
Watt?
Er ist gebackt.
Er ist entbackt.
Moinsi-Sigi-Bula. Ich habe es geschafft, alle beide zu verfehlen.
Und schon wieder stunnen.
Das ist übrigens OP.
Ist er down? Ja, er ist down.
Da hängt er. Den wir releasen sollen.
Warum halten die Gegner auf einmal so viel aus?
Oh, nice.
Der andere Typ ist auch down.
Achso, die halten so viel aus, weil ich nicht das Org-Schwert verwende.
Der buggt irgendwie ein bisschen, oder?
Das ist ein Special-Gegner. Der sieht anders aus, aber der macht nichts.
Der buggt rum und der eigene Typ feiert ihn gerade.
Genau, wack.
Du möchtest von mir runtergetreten werden, oder?
Du hast ja geradezu danach geschrien, Alter.
Du auch.
Also der hat ja wirklich schon gesagt, bitte kick mich runter gerade.
Moment, wie soll man hier genau laufen? So?
So, und du?
Ah, ein Seil dran schießen.
Ich mag diese Physik-Gestellte von der Source-Engine.
Fuck!
Ja, kriegste noch was.
Mit.
Machen wir. Machen wir alles.
Kill-Points, 13. Wir können noch, wir können Vitalitätsbecken, automatischer Life-Rack.
Das ist sehr, sehr nice.
Life-Rack können wir nie genug haben.
Da setzt sich gerade was ran von hinten.
Der Kick ist geil, ja. Wird das Beste eigentlich an dem Game, also kampfsystemtechnisch.
Schreckt.
Nochmal.
Die normalen Zombies können wirklich gar nichts.
Sind das überhaupt Zombies? Nee, das ist nicht so wirklich, ne?
Das sind auf jeden Fall irgendwelche Untote.
Tyrannosaurus schreckt.
Die müssen wir ein bisschen, erstmal die, erstmal die Dinger baschen.
Nice!
In your face-Kick.
Nichts wie weg.
Macht kaum Damage.
Der sieht nichts.
Nichts wie weg, weg, weg, weg, weg.
Wie ist denn die offiziell gedachte Taktik hier?
Meint ihr das geht?
Ernsthaft? Nice!
So als würde es mir das Viech schon noch hier reinlocken.
Komm her! Wo bist du?
Zyklop!
Komm her!
Hier, auf!
Da genau, dahin, da ist gut.
Und jetzt BÄM!
Nein, das hat nicht funktioniert.
Der hat es einfach weggekickt.
Okay, wir müssen unsere Jump-Slash-Action wieder ausführen.
Das Viech kann überhaupt nichts, ne?
Das ist übelst räudig eigentlich. Einfach ein paar mal Jump-Slashen und Down ist es.
Ich muss noch was ausführen. Was passiert, wenn ich vor dem Viech stehe, wenn es umfällt?
Äh, nichts.
Hätte er sein können.
Ich finde es schade, dass Half-Life 2, also zu dieser Zeit von Half-Life 2, weil es ja voll im Trend, dass Games so ein bisschen Physik-Zeug dann gemacht haben, also die ganzen Source-Engine-Games.
Ich finde eigentlich blöd, dass sich das nicht etabliert hat.
Es gibt sau wenig Games mit so Physik-Spielereien oder mit glaubhafter Physik zumindest.
Guckt euch mal Skyrim an zum Beispiel. Da hittet ein irgendwas und man fliegt gefühlt 30 Kilometer über den Berg.
Pilz. Ihr glaubt doch nicht ernsthaft, dass das hier funktioniert.
Auch die nehmen noch. Können wir mal meine Bogenskills auspacken. Die ungespeckte Level-0-Bogenskills.
Also man sieht mein Bogen macht mega Damage. Fast wie der Minecraft-Bogen ungefähr.
Ansonsten ist es ziemlich useless meine Bogenskills.
Was haben wir denn hier so zu bieten?
Aha. Sehr, sehr nice.
Nix gibt's. Ich lasse dich auch nicht stunnen, wie er sich heilt.
Hat ihm aber auch nichts gebracht.
Next-Level-Archery. Da gab es doch so ein Video, ne?
So ein Typ, der dann irgendwie so mit drei Pfeilen im Springen und so geschossen hat.
Aber halt irgendwie nur aus zwei Meter Entfernung. Mit einem Bogen, der sich wahrscheinlich mit dem kleinen Finger spannen lässt.
Aber kann ich sagen, das war vor ein paar Jahren ja so ein ziemlich viral Video.
Das hieß doch auch Next-Level-Archery. Oder so ähnlich zumindest.
Nichts wie weg.
Röstorz.
Mal gucken, was passiert.
Mal gucken, was mit dir. Ah, passiert nichts. So gut ist die Physik-Engine und die Simulation auch nicht.
Cheater. Ja, das ist wie bei Dan. Cheater auf Gewatsch oder wie das hieß, ne?
Dan's Gaming ist besser als der Let's-Player. Beziehungsweise auch der einzige Let's-Player, der den Schwert gucken kann.
Der Zack hat eine Falle. Das weiß ich noch. Kann ich mir noch dran erinnern.
Guckt. Bam.
Ich glaube, da hat der Skyrim gespielt und hat sich irgendwie halt über den Abgrund gecheatet. Irgendwie sowas war das.
Oh. Das sind die fetten Guards da unten.
Die protecten. Aber wir attacken jetzt.
Next, please.
Okay, die sind relativ unbeeindruckt davon, ob sie einen Fass oder sonst was an den Kopf kriegen oder nicht.
Die halten doch ganz gut was aus, die Jungs.
Die muss man eigentlich aufschießen, dass man sie down kriegt ordentlich.
Was war das für eine Ultimate?
Das sind die Billigwachen, die können nix.
Was ich geil finde, das finde ich auch geil, wie es sich die Entwickler gedacht haben.
Wenn ein Gegner wegrennt, habt ihr gerade gesehen, und man switcht auf Dagger, kann man den Dagger nach dem werfen.
Guckt. Der rennt weg. Dagger switch. Range kill.
Poggers, Alter. Poggers.
Es werden hier immer mehr.
Perfekt.
Prepare to die.
So einfach ist es nicht. Vor allem nicht, wenn man OP 90 HP hat und alle möglichen Skills schon.
Das ist der Vater.
Er arbeitet nicht so sehr durcheinander.
Okay, der kämpft jetzt wahrscheinlich für mich.
Ja, anscheinend.
Das ist der Slow-Mo-Guy-Fighter. Die können sich nur in Slow-Motion bewegen und rumklatschen, die Typen.
Achtung.
Perfekt.
Also für das, dass das ein Boss sein soll, sind sie ziemlich mies.
Glitch.
Da fliegt er.
Wir fliegen den jetzt ins Feuer.
Moment, er lebt noch? Nein, er lebt nicht mehr.
Er musste noch mal aufstehen, um seine Death-Animation abzuspielen und dann vorbei.
Ich glaube, Leute, das ist der letzte oder vorletzte Raum. Danach sind wir durch.
Oh, da ist ein Gegner.
Ich sehe nur einen Blutspritzer gerade.
Ich habe gerade außer Blutspritzer nichts gesehen.
Wer konnte denn damit rechnen jetzt?
Nein, nein, nein, nicht noch mal.
Nehmen wir jetzt mal einen Stein, hauen es demnächst an den Kopf.
Komm her. Er evaded wieder. Nochmal.
L'amonitaneier.
Pure Heart, wir sind nicht Pure Heart.
Oh, die meinen das ernst, oder?
Die meinen das ernst. Man kann es nicht verwenden, wenn man das Steam-Quill dabei hat.
Egal, ich habe genug Leben, ich habe genug Tränke, ich brauche das alles nicht.
Kopf ab.
Bleibst du hier?
Ja, also mit dem, mit Daggers kann man werfen, wenn man Special-Mehle-Angriff hat, also wenn man hier Adrenalin aufgeladen hat.
Hier ist nichts.
Okay, Endgegner-Time.
Sieht man das Steam-Quill nochmal? Jaja, kommt noch, kommt noch.
Allerdings das, was du dir vorstellst, wahrscheinlich nicht, oder was du gerne hättest, wahrscheinlich eher nicht.
Weil wir sind hier eher ein familienfreundlicher, christlicher Stream, da geht sowas nicht.
Ja, das ist bei Demon-Quills auch so, vor der Ehe läuft da nichts.
Geht's denn lang? Da.
Da unten ist er.
Der Necromancer.
Loll.
Invisible Stealth.
Wie wir die Zauber von dem kein Damage machen, weil ich wahrscheinlich Endo-Gespekt habe.
Bam.
Der kann überhaupt nichts, der Typ.
Komm mal, der kann sich unsichtbar stellen, als würde man den nicht sehen.
Das ist das schlechteste Unsichtbarkeitszauber ever, den ich kenne.
Easy Win. Durchgespielt.
Next Game please.
Ok, G-Bate, es geht auch noch weiter.
Das wird der Dragon geowned, komm her.
Darauf den Schwanz hauen.
Alter, was ist das? Ah, Hit.
Hallo, kann ich den mal hitten? Wenn ich ihn hitte, bringt nichts, ne?
Jawoll, Hit. Ah, jetzt kann ich ihn hitten.
Komm her, Drache.
Her, komm, her, komm.
Mein Damage macht er nicht wegen meines Facts.
Hallo, Drache, kannst du mal jetzt runter?
Kein Bock. Mir reicht's jetzt, Leute. Ich pack jetzt meinen Level-1-Bogen aus.
Easy Level-1-Bogen. Easy Level-1-Bogen.
Level-1-Bogen, beste.
Der leuchtet so, der macht bestimmt gleich Ultimate oder sowas.
Der war ein krasser, ungeskillter Level-1-Bogen gegen den Boss, lol.
Bam.
GG.
So, letzte Entscheidung des Games. Wollen wir unseren Vater befreien oder wollen wir das Artefakt selbst nehmen und krasser Owner dieses Landes werden?
Ach ja, hätten wir übrigens das Magiacrill gewählt und nicht Xana, dann hätten wir die Chance gehabt, die Dämonen zu vernichten.
Was wir jetzt nicht haben, weil wir selber einer sind.
Selbst nehmen für Big Balls, ja, wir nehmen den selbst.
So, jetzt wirklich GG.
So, das war's für heute.